what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time i'm here with
the beautiful intelligent all red
looking like christmas polina marinova
coming it's approaching listen we don't
need any christmas yet we haven't even
had halloween thanksgiving then
christmas if you put out your christmas
decorations right now
you're a psycho don't forget that lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
five has three products you can deposit
crypto and take out a usd loan and get
your crypto collateral you can buy and
sell crypto on their crypto exchange or
number three my favorite product as an
investor a user a board member
and a very happy proponent of the
company is an interest-bearing account
where you can earn up to 8.6 percent apy
in that interest bearing account go sign
up for a block by account
no brainer i use it first monday every
month is block five
day because you just get that interest
payments and it's awesome
block five.com guys he got nine hours of
sleep last night so now we're gonna
get all of the energy a boy might be
sleeping 10 tonight
he doesn't know this yet but i set him
up for a rant today and
i personally don't want to hear it but i
know you guys do so
let's go facebook and twitter clamp
down on new york post's hunter biden
story after saying they won't be the
arbitra arbiters of truth
they seem to be the arbiters of truth um
basically in the run-up to november's
election online platforms have designed
circuit breakers to limit the spread of
hacked email and foreign meddling
in 2016 such material helped shape the
political fight
except those circuit breakers tripped
after the new york post story reported
allegations about joe biden's son
based on what the paper said were emails
provided to it
sunday and twitter and facebook
reduced its distribution
let's go all i'm gonna say okay
all i'm gonna say is that
we have now entered a world you idiots
you idiots
on the internet who is you idiots oh
they know who it is
you idiots have put us in a world where
we now have
technology platforms fact checking
oh yeah the fact checkers who are
supposed to be the journalist
there is zero zero
world that i want to be living in where
we give
this power to technology companies so
you trust the media
it's not that i trust the media it's
that fake news
lies spins that's been part of the media
forever forever this is equivalent
of the phone company saying ah
paulina's lying to him on the phone
we're gonna cut this call off
we're gonna cut this call off right and
i get yes there's algorithms there's all
these things
but ultimately what we need is we need
to solve the problem not at the
distribution point you need to solve the
problem
at the media point so do you want to
solve this problem here's what you do
you implement a federal law that says
if you're a media organization and you
publish something
that is provably false that is provably
false
you will serve a financial fine you have
to pay a fine it's a great
for publishing things that are provably
false now here's the thing
if it's in the gray area fine and
there's there's no thing
but then there's opinion then there it's
just again
but you got to solve it because right
now you're doing free speech
i don't mess with you what you're doing
right now is you're
you have no process you know anything
you completely offloaded that decision
making to corporations
and just whatever they want who's who's
checking what twitter's doing who's
checking what facebook's doing
by the way what their explanation was
around oh these emails
actually have the email addresses in
there right okay fine if that breaks the
rules then tell the people hey
you have to go ahead and block out or
redact that email address
and then and then it's viable so my
whole point is
the problem isn't the distribution
platforms the problem is
at the top the people who are writing
the articles if you want to solve that
problem
right that's the problem it's not the
distribution platforms we're solving for
the wrong thing because we have outrage
culture
and all these idiots on the internet are
running around and they're trying to
just
pressure these technology companies into
doing things that makes
zero sense it makes zero i certainly
don't want mark zuckerberg telling me
what i can and cannot publish
uh but i think there's yeah it's a very
interesting problem it's kind of like
the chicken or the egg just like
professional athletes you do something
that breaks the rules of the league
you get fined well we need to create a
organization that oversees the media
and says if you lie we do not need to
live in a government-run media
state no it doesn't have to be a
government organization a federal law
the federal law is that has to be
implemented but it can be overseen by a
private organization no i don't like it
okay well right now there's journalistic
ethics groups yes is there journalists
okay
so is there journalistic ethics everyone
should look up spj
society of professional journalists and
they have a code of ethics
that what okay but it's just you know is
there to guide i think
yeah it's just the whole it's basically
like here's some suggestions how about
we start putting some teeth behind it
find these people when they lie that
will immediately
trust me it's like the banks because you
know what the media companies will do
they'll start budgeting in the fines
into their business model
that's false so this is thanks to it
okay but then you're perpetuating this
culture you're not actually
solving the problem you're saying oh
just go do it and then we'll budget in
our money we'll just pay the fine it
doesn't matter
hold on what i'm saying is
it's really hard to prove that somebody
is
lying like you put it because you have
to prove malicious intent you have to
prove that the reporter or the media
organization
knew what they were publishing was
factual like was was actually inaccurate
and they did it anyway that is
what lying is defined as so
they do that all the time it's a no you
don't know that
it's a bigger problem the problem is
that
everything has been politicized so what
to you as a fact
to me is like not a fact and something
else is a it's just
really really bad so i think that there
needs to be more
education around what the what freedom
of speech is
and uh the ethics
i am appalled at what some of these
media organizations are doing because if
you look at the sbj code of ethics
they're not being followed you can't
enforce it unless there's a penalty
yes but you just said they're gonna uh
save money to pay that penalty of course
no no no of course some will do that but
not all of them will do it the point is
you have to have a penalty
second thing that was my first point i'm
not i'm just getting warmed up
my second thing is free speech the whole
point of free speech
is not to allow free speech of those you
agree with
it's all about do you protect free
speech
even when somebody is saying something
that you disagree with guys he went to
war
to do that i didn't say that she said
that
i don't that's not a thing for me the
the point being
if you do not empower the people
who say something you disagree with then
you are just as bad
as those who are against the free speech
okay so we agree on that
third point oh geez you're crazy you're
legitimately crazy if you think you
cannot talk too much
all these politicians on both sides of
the aisle are corrupt
if you do not this whole story is
absolutely true
there's zero chance that this story's
not true you do not think or if you
think
if you uh if you think the politicians
are not corrupt
you've lost your mind you're literally
living in la la land that is government
both sides of the aisle are corrupt
that's how politics works
and by the way we're seeing accusations
against both sides
for the same things there's no
difference they're all doing the same
things
some would argue actually an intelligent
argument would be well that's how
politics are done
is you actually have to use some level
of
negotiation tactics threats posturing et
cetera right like in this ukrainian
i hate it too but my point is that would
be a better defense
than to say we did not do it because
it's provably
false when they say that and so what
you're seeing right now is the internet
has
exposed all this nonsense and now
all of a sudden you can simply get a
story
write it on the internet and it can rip
through society
and people will debate is it true is it
not whatever the point being
it's all corrupt it's all corrupt and
the people are waking up to it and the
people are realizing no matter what you
do
i do she does or anybody else it ain't
gonna change
it is not that's not going to be corrupt
yes
think about this story for a second
right hold on you've got you've got the
sitting vice president at the time
who is on stage there's a video of him
on stage
saying that he withheld aid until
somebody in a foreign government was
fired again
what the reason was all this stuff is up
for debate but just think about that for
a second
imagine if somebody in a foreign
government
came to us and said hey we're going to
give you x but you know what you got to
get rid of the attorney general
or you got to get rid of whoever i don't
care what the politics are this happens
on both sides of the aisle
and the point being that if you actually
want to be able to critique what's going
on in politics
you have to allow the media to do that
and what that means is
sometimes you're going to disagree with
what they write sometimes you're going
to question
how they wrote it why they wrote it
right where their sources come from
but it's not for the technology compass
it's not for the platforms to decide
that you have to let the american people
decide that um
all that to say
pump and pimp 2024. can i say one more
thing
wait is it 2024 thank you for allowing
me to rant about this
you're welcome i know the people free
speech oh
there you go should be prioritized let's
go lessons learned
u.s equity valuations have become a
total nightmare
nightmare fueled by young and dumb
investors according to cole smead
president portfolio manager at smead
capital management
at president
at present investors are paying 22 times
forward earnings to purchase stocks on
the s
p 500 50 higher than the 10-year average
valuations across the index
listen just so we're clear he's saying
that
cole smith i'm sure is a nice guy i'm
sure
i'm sure he's a nice guy
but if you really think some robin hood
traders
are fueling this market you lost your
mind that's also true
you've lost your mind you want to blame
somebody you go
blame your elected officials who have
created three trillion dollars in
quantitative easing
and increase the fed's balance sheet by
75
and you go talk to the federal reserve
who can't help themselves but to
intervene in markets
and are flooding the market with cash
and drug and emergency cut interest
rates twice
down to zero percent don't blame the
kids the kids ain't do this the kids are
just smarter than you and they're the
ones who are capturing all the profits
right now
because the kids got handed money by the
government right during the
heart of the downturn and they all went
and put it in stocks
and so the kids are actually smarter
than you but they ain't fueling this
they got no money there's no money
that's me there's no money these kids
have
where they got a couple billion dollars
total that's not doing anything
you're talking about a federal
government that took out a monetary
stimulus
bazooka they literally and they just
fired three trillion dollars into the
market sorry cole
i'm sure you're a nice guy never met you
before i like you
i like the fact that your name is cole
smead and you named your firm after
yourself that's something that i would
do
but the kids ain't do this keep it
focused on who did it the federal
reserve how much money
have the politicians and the chairman of
the federal reserve made they're worth
tens of
millions of dollars everyone wants to
write articles about the billionaires
made half a trillion dollars during the
pandemic
how much do the politicians make who
wrote the legislation
how much chairman make small point but
cuomo came out with his book yesterday i
don't know how much he's charging for it
but like he's selling books during the
pandemic about
lessons and nobody's buying it of
leadership during the pandemic
and nobody's buying we're making money
off of this right now he's like number
777
uh most popular on the list ain't nobody
buying your book so maybe he's not
making money but the point is don't be
trying to make money while the people
are suffering
guy got 10 10 plus thousand people
killed by putting people back in the
uh retirement he that's what he did in
elderly care that there's
let's just call it i'm trying my best
not to censor guys
let's call it a fact of fact there was a
rule there was a rule created by the
governor and the governor said
you have to take the covid patients back
and put them in the elderly care
and then new york had the most elderly
care deaths it ravaged
because of that rule guys but you wrote
a book and nobody bought
when we were in austin someone stopped
us
and told anthony that they really liked
his
rants like thoughts rants thoughts
i call them rants whatever let's go next
you know who is benefiting from the fans
know why people like this show
is because i just say the truth who who
else is going to call out this idiot
okay polino wants them to open up the
restaurant
no kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm
kidding i'm kidding all right
they are open for the record um you know
who is benefiting from
uh pandemic cable news networks
also who the hell on this planet is
watching cable news i thought anybody
under the age of like 80
doesn't watch cable anymore it's the
politics
it's this no i guess social justice
issues it's it's but why are they
watching cnn and fox that's not where
you should go to get your
political news because
it's like a train wreck no one can turn
their face away so basically
everyone wants to watch the train wreck
and those people are putting the train
wreck on display listen to this
collectively the news networks cnn fox
news and msnbc averaged just under 10
million
viewers in prime time last week or 72
more than the same week in 2019 at a
time most networks are grateful not to
lose too many viewers
year to year fox news average of 4.42
million last week was up 63
msnbc's 2.75 million was up 38
and cnn's 2.59 million
172 percent up here's what i'm going to
explain to you you want to know
out of those fox is up 60 msnbc is up 40
and cnn's up 170 you want to know why
cnn's up 170
because they think this is a game they
think this is a game
if you go and watch cnn they literally
have coveted deaths
on there like the sports scoreboard
that's what they're doing they have it
up like a scoreboard
so basically i think it's
the older demographic that is watching
these things
i don't know anyone my age who sits down
and watches
like genuinely watches fox and cnn
or msnbc they've all unplugged
they're all watching much money all
right next
that was a rant um just telling the
truth
walmart ceo doug mcmillan said the
retailer wants to own part of popular
video app tick tock because it sees
social media as a huge business
opportunity and a powerful way to reach
customers the deal which includes
chinese parent company by dance
and oracle that's not a chinese parent
is not
yet finalized and must get government
approval
mcmillan said the retailer is talking
about dance about ways to make
social commerce easier and more
appealing for american customers
this is smart so basically i'm gonna go
and talk and be able to buy from walmart
some version of that i mean look if i've
seen companies that are making it so
like when you see a video
literally there's a thing on the screen
you can immediately click and it takes
you to a checkout for that item
i've seen things where in the
description it somehow is able to use
like
machine learning or something and
identify the objects and then put the
links in the description
yes so i understand this is smart
because right now
tick tock is not well monetized i don't
think anyone's really making any real
money off of it
so smart for walmart but is the tick
tock demographic
the walmart customer i don't think
they're shopping at walmart
i think that uh actually if walmart
has the online ordering capabilities if
they can get
feature parody with amazon yeah uh
people don't care
anymore like i'm just ordering it
offline just have it shove it to my
house
right but i'm just saying like well
maybe maybe that's the demographic i'm
on but there's a lot
you're older than the demographic on
tick tock yeah no i'm saying
there's a young demographic there
shopping for these like cool clothes
i'm not sure they're at walmart i think
that they don't have enough money
uh to go shop elsewhere and walmart
prides itself on being the low-cost
provider
of goods did you just call me old
i'm going to i'm old too what the hell
okay billionaire robert f smith
robert f smith founder of vista equity
partners and the wealthiest black man in
america will settle a
four-year federal investigation into tax
crimes
for 140 million dollars doesn't he wish
he'd had just paid
smith reportedly won't be prosecuted but
as part of the settlement the
billionaire must
admit wrongdoing and assist in other
federal tax investigations being
conducted
the 140 million figures derived from
back taxes penalties
and interest yikes dude
what do you think yeah i really like
robert's i do too
this is a lot i did not know that we
were going to talk about all this today
are you okay yeah i really like i really
like robert smith a lot
um so a couple of things just initial
reaction
one uh there's this is not
insider trading or any like securities
fraud or anything like that it appears
at least from what i'm reading right now
uh so like sac capital type situation
that's not that
this is specifically around tax evasion
i saw a chart once of the structure
nightmare absolute nightmare i mean so
complex and by the way like
when you're this wealthy of course
you've got all kinds of things
everywhere
in different countries like what
whatever he's worth 5.2
billion yeah and uh so like that's one
thing
the second thing then is uh usually in
these cases when you settle
if the figure's big enough they don't
have to admit
wrong doing so admitting wrong doing is
like that's like a
key piece there that's why it's not what
i would expect i think they would make
him do that
again this is complete speculation it
probably they had a lot of evidence
right and so this was like hey we're not
budging on this
uh what is crazy if you've never read
the book there's a book called black
edge
i think it's called it's all about the
sac capital situation
um if you read it what shocked me was
uh there's like a negotiation with the
regulators
um which is not how i thought that these
things played out but
i suggest reading that book cause i
think it's just very telling as to kind
of how these investigations work
and all that stuff i don't know enough
about this here uh
but it does look like it was basically
failing to pay u.s taxes on around 200
million dollars in assets
that moved from uh vista's first private
equity fund through a bunch of entities
and somehow it ended up in like a
non-profit
but the way that it like went through
the structures
ended up being um like almost like he
got paid and then it went into a
non-profit structure so if i remember
the whole story correctly and again
don't hold me to this but like it ended
up going to a place
that was a non-profit and i think he
ended up giving it away
oh yeah i knew this was going on i just
didn't know that there was a settlement
um today and so uh there was like this
weird thing where they were trying to
track the flow of the fonts that's all
well when you make something super
complicated eventually somebody's gonna
try to
yeah okay yeah and okay let's just keep
going
the wii company remember the wii company
drops the wii name to restore the wework
name
because it can't get confusing enough
the wii company parent of
money losing shared office provider
wework which last year yanked plans to
go public
is dropping the wii moniker to revert
its better known name
wework going back to its roots so why
are they doing that
uh it probably just signals the fact
that maybe we shouldn't go and have a
preschool
and uh whatever other crazy things they
were doing
uh maybe we should just focus on being a
shared office space company
and that's probably a pretty good
opportunity it's weird that they like
own the name
we like or the word weed whatever sorry
so so wework is back i guess to some
degree i like it
look at this we want to be strategic we
want to be innovative we want to be
impactful
we want to be we work so many puns on
puns
okay ready for my joke speaking of puns
what a great transition go ahead
due to the pandemic we should all avoid
buying butter
butter why butter together
we can stop the spread
somebody said that they get ready for
the great silence after my joke
you are the great silence because
they're not they're so
funny when i tell jokes people laugh you
tell jokes
we all fall asleep you gotta let
yourself go let yourself
oh guys if you follow paulina me on
youtube
in the next few days there might be a
surprise a little actually a little
surprise
nugget little topic that polina didn't
include but i'm gonna talk about it real
quick
narrative violation what narrative
violation
violation breaking this morning
democratic presidential candidates
now have covid positive staff members so
the whole talk about
uh it was republicans but whatever again
like i said
both political parties are the same
they're both the same but no
but now they both have cochlear implant
doesn't discriminate based on your
political of course
of course but the narrative was like oh
these people aren't taking it seriously
that's why they got it
and maybe that's true or maybe it's not
but now both political parties have
plenty of people who took it very
seriously who got it
my point being got it don't listen to
the divisive nature
they're all the same listen to lunch
money they're all the same
that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed it leave a comment i'm sure some
of you all got some hot takes
i'll try to read it later today see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends